es gibt durchaus was zu feiern im
jubiläumsjahr der einheit aber natürlich
haben wir auch ein paar probleme 1 ist
die überalterung in deutschland die gibt
es in ganz deutschland aber der osten
über altert schneller
müssen wir uns sorgen machen ja ich
finde wir können schlecht ein jubiläum
feiern und uns gleichzeitig über
überalterung beschweren werden auch
altern kann ist wenigstens noch nicht
tot
selbst ich und das klingt jetzt für die
zuschauer verblüffend ich werde langsam
älter ich bin jetzt 25 geworden
ich weiß das ist jetzt nicht klassisch
alt aber für mich ist es ein rekord
merck auch noch nicht an mir selber dass
ich älter werde aber meine eltern werden
langsam älter und das muss ja heißen
dass ich auch langsam älter werde meine
eltern sind noch nicht so richtig alt
aber schon so dass es spannend wird also
wir sind jetzt in dem alter wo wenn sie
sich ein teures möbelstück kaufen dann
will ich gerne mitreden welches
aber wir haben ein gutes verhältnis ich
versuche sie alle paar monate zu
besuchen und jedes mal wenn ich sie sehe
können sie etwas neues nicht mehr
älterwerden kann auch spannend sein man
muss einfach sein verhältnis zu spaß neu
denken der spaß bei einem büro partie
besteht zum beispiel nicht darin selber
spaß zu haben sondern einfach sagen zu
können okay also ich hab keinen spaß
ich würde gerne leuten die ich nicht mag
dabei zuschauen wie die auch keinen spaß
haben und wenn man lange genug gealtert
ist kann man auch glücklich sein ohne
spaß zu haben in dem man vernünftig ist
quittungen sammelt sachen von der steuer
abgesetzt wo sie jetzt natürlich ein
bisschen aufpassen von wo aus die leute
zu hause zuschauern bestimmt sitzen
gerade welche in stuttgart die jetzt
denken wahrscheinlich
sag mal hast du trittst ja wie ich
gelesen habe auch öfter mal in den neuen
ländern auf wie erlebst du die menschen
da gibt es ja immer noch unterschiede
die duh wahrnimmst ich versteh gar nicht
was diese unterteilung in die neuen und
die alten bundesländer überhaupt soll
hey was gefällt dir besser der osten der
westen potsdam düsseldorf keine ahnung
also ich bin in der schweiz aufgewachsen
und ganz ehrlich für mich ist dass
beides dritte welt klar die ostdeutschen
die mögen andere sachen eine freundin
von mir hat mich vor kurzem dort zu
einem mittelaltermarkt eingeladen sie
ist jetzt nicht mehr meine freundin
mittelaltermarkt falls sie noch nie da
waren es ist so ein abgetrenntes fällt
in brandenburg man kommt hin und denkt
sich ok also ich habe ja schon viel
negatives über dieses bundesland gehört
aber das hier ist ja noch um einiges
beschissener als alles was ich mir
jemals hätte vorstellen können
und egal wo er ist egal wann er ist der
mittelaltermarkt immer vor genau drei
stunden aufgehört zu regnen
gegen wohl steht noch so ein biorn in
einem glocken kostüm herum und schalmei
etwas es gibt stockbrot für sechs euro
50 und suppe im brot für neun euro 50
suppe im brot ein sehr schwieriges
gericht weil die super am anfang viel zu
heiß um sie zu essen aber dann
irgendwann ohne vorwarnung gibt es pro
behältnis plötzlich sein geist auch man
steht daran suppe getränkten feuchten
teig ring in der hand und suppe überall
auf der hose verschüttet und niemand
freut sich dort zu sein
alle leute sind so mittel gut drauf alle
leute sind so mittel gerne dort alle
leute sind so mittelalt deswegen heißt
der markt ja auch so
und nicht einmal jemanden aus dem echten
mittelalter dem wird das dort gefallen
der wird rauskommen aus seiner
zeitmaschine wenn er hier in brandenburg
von 2009/10 katapultiert würde kommt aus
der zeitmaschine raus und dem wird auch
nicht gefallen er wird sagen hey was
geht denn hier ab
also spricht natürlich ein bisschen
anders kommt ja aus dem mittelalter sie
sagen etwas kaschiert hier spricht
einfach wie so ein schweizer der
angefahren wurde und dann würde sich
fragen was sagen was hier suppe im brot
das hatten wir nicht
wir hatten entweder suppe oder brot
meisters hatten wir gar nichts und jeder
hatte eine schüssel geschnitzt aus der
wirbelsäule des großvaters und wenn die
schüssel kaputt gegangen ist ist man
verwundert ja danke für den exkurs es
ist vielleicht auch mal zur ehrenrettung
des schönen brandenburg man kann das
schon spaß haben
theoretisch ja klar ich will jetzt den
osten gar nicht aufs mittelalter
reduziert es gibt ja auch andere märkte
in brandenburg ich war damals in einem
anderen markt kaufhof galeria hieß das
dach war mega ich bin rein gekommen
gegen meinen willen mit papa an
geschmiert worden dann bin ich runter in
einer delikatessen abteilung ich habe
eine dattel im speckmantel gegessen eine
frucht in einer sau was will man mehr
hamburg zu tun klingt aber lecker heißer
butter doch